digamos que ya es igual a 6 entre x al
cuadrado lo que quiero que hagamos en
este vídeo es encontrar cuál es la
segunda derivada de y con respecto a x
ahora si te estás preguntando de dónde
salió esta anotación para la segunda
derivada de y bueno pues imaginemos que
tenemos ahí y tomamos su derivada con
respecto de x esta anotación ya la hemos
visto aquí tenemos a la derivada de y
con respecto a x0 para sacar la segunda
derivada de y volvemos a derivar todo
esto con respecto a x y es de aquí de
donde sale esta anotación porque
podríamos decir que aquí tenemos dos
veces y entonces ponemos aquí hunde al
cuadrado aunque aquí estas veces no se
están multiplicando más bien estamos
utilizando el operador derivar dos veces
y aquí también tenemos de equis dos
veces
pero no se está multiplicando estamos
aplicando el operador dos veces así es
que es de aquí de donde sale esta
anotación y ahora vamos a empezar
sacando la primera derivada de i con
respecto de equis y para hacer eso nada
más tenemos que aplicar la regla de las
potencias porque aquí tenemos igual
/ x al cuadrado pero eso lo podemos
escribir como x elevado a la potencia
menos 2 entonces vamos a encontrar la
derivada con respecto de x de ambas
expresiones del lado izquierdo tenemos
la derivada de y con respecto de x
del lado derecho nada más tenemos que
recordar que la regla de las potencias
toma el exponente y lo multiplica por el
coeficiente y entonces nos queda menos
12 por equis a la el exponente menos 1 -
2 - 1 es menos 3 queremos volver a
derivar con respecto de x
así es que volvemos a aplicar el
operador derivar con respecto de x el
lado izquierdo es la segunda derivada de
y con respecto a x que va a ser igual a
bueno pues aquí volvemos a utilizar la
regla de las potencias tomamos el
exponente lo multiplicamos por el
coeficiente menos 3 x menos 12 es 36 con
signo positivo 36 por equis a la menos
tres menos uno pero menos tres menos uno
es menos cuatro pero esto también lo
podemos escribir como 36 entre x a la 4
y listo ya terminamos